[Music]
a lot has changed since the last god of
war game sure kratos is still angry and
hates the gods more than anything but
that's about where the similarities end
god of war takes cues from Metroidvania
style games and creates a more
open-ended journey with
over-the-shoulder third-person combat if
you're used to the God of War of old
then hopefully this video will help you
get started on your new adventure hey
also I'm gonna try my damnedest to avoid
spoilers in this video but if you want
to go in with as little prior knowledge
as possible maybe come back and watch
this later
[Music]
you'll reach a point in this story where
the world opens up and allows you to
explore more freely and you should
absolutely take time out of crate doses
busy schedule and take in the sights not
only is the game gorgeous but there's
also a ton of useful items tucked away
in every nook and cranny when you reach
the lake of the nine check out different
parts of the lake and areas that might
not be marked you can even find side
quests that will net you a nice bit of
XP and other goodies oh and every time
you stumble on a chest marked with runes
you should spend the time to open them
these usually contain items that will
increase your maximum health and rage
meter neglecting these can put you at a
significant disadvantage later in the
game
your standard combos are great and all
but if you want a bit more variety in
your dragger slang skill set don't
forget about runic abilities you can
equip two at a time a light ability and
a heavy one to use these you'll need to
hold l1 and press either r1 or r2 if
used at the right time these can
dramatically change the tide of battle
they do have a lengthy cooldown those so
use them wisely
make sure to experiment with different
runic abilities as you find and unlock
new ones and if you stumble on a few you
like you can upgrade them in the menus
[Music]
you don't earn a whole lot of XP during
the early hours of god of War's so it's
important to choose your skills wisely
there are multiple skill trees for crate
docent at Reyes so it can feel a bit
overwhelming at first after you've
gotten a feel for combat figure out the
play style that best suits you and focus
your XP on that I ignored at Reyes at
first and only focused on kratos axe and
shield combat
fortunately you earn experience at a
quicker rate the further along you get
this is when I started to expand my
skills and try out different perks and
abilities that may not have fit my
initial play style although at Reyes is
roughly 1/100 the size of Kratos he can
be pretty useful in battles he'll stun
and distract enemies and let you know if
there's someone behind you especially on
harder difficulties this can mean life
or death for Kratos so make sure to keep
the boy outfitted with top-of-the-line
equipment also make sure to pay a visit
to a skill tree every now and then as
you make your way through the story
he'll unlock electric arrows and light
arrows if you upgrade these he can keep
enemies at bay while you rip something
limb from limb
[Applause]
if you find a set of armor you like you
can outfit it with some enchantments
these can give you a significant edge in
battle however when you find your Forge
a better set of armor don't forget to
transfer all your enchantments over to a
new set unless of course you like making
things harder on yourself for no reason
[Music]
later on you'll discover realms that are
completely optional without spoiling
what you do in these realms we highly
encourage you to visit them and complete
the challenges within completing them
can net use some special crafting
resources used to make some of the best
armors in the game God of War is much
deeper than its predecessors and
requires a bit more thought and strategy
than before if you have any tips that
have helped you along your journey then
leave them in the comments below thank
you for watching
[Music]